ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BURNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE ALLEN CARILLO CERVANTES
CHAU.
TRAN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOL HE COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA AS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KILEY
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE.
LOW MOAN.
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MODEL [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS.
REYES THREE OF US.
ROBERT READ THIS [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESIDENT IS SIMPLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA REVENUE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
ALTHOUGH ONLY BEGINNING OUR
THIRD MAN.
MANY HAVE SAID TO ME THAT.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN HAS
ALREADY BEEN OVERFLOWING WITH
DIFFICULT CHANGES AND LOSSES.
IN LIVING LIFE WE KNOW THAT WE
WILL FACE DIFFICULT CHALLENGES.
AND THE PAINFUL LOSS OF PEOPLE
WE LOVE.
IN OUR MINDS WE NOTE THIS IS A
PART OF THE CYCLE OF LIFE.
BUT IN OUR HEARTS WE ALWAYS WISH
IT DID NOT HAVE TO BE SO.
BUT WE MUST SOMEHOW FIND OUR WAY
THROUGH THE TIMES OF EMPTINESS
AND DESPAIR. TO BE ABLE TO SEE
AGAIN THE VALUE OF THIS WONDROUS
DREAM OF LIFE.
WE KNOW THERE LAST BUT A MOMENT.
AND WE MUST SAVOR EACH NEW DAY.
YES STILL THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
MY HEART JUST ACHES.
BUT THE LOSSES THAT LIFE HAS
BROUGHT OUR WAY.
IF THERE COULD ONLY BE MAGIC TO
RETURN TO US THE CONTENTMENT OF
HAPPY HAPPIER DAYS.
DAYS SHARED WITH THOSE WE LOVE
AND MISS SO MUCH.
I KNOW WHERE IS IT WRITTEN THAT
LIFE IS EASY.
NO WHERE IS A PROMISE THAT LIFE
WILL BE FAIR.
EACH OF US IS BORN WITH A UNIQUE
AND WONDERFUL LIFE.
IN WITHIN THE SPAN OF OUR
LIFETIMES.
WE MUST LEARN TO ACCEPT OUR
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND DO THE BEST THAT WE CAN. TO
LIVE AS BEST WE CAN.
ALWAYS DOING THE BEST WE CAN.
IF WE DO THE BEST WE CAN. TO
LIVE WITH OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN.
WE WILL SEE HOW PRECIOUS EACH
DAY TRULY IS.
WITH OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN.
WE WILL CHERISH EVERY
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE WITH THE
PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES.
HAVE GIVEN MEANING TO OUR OWN.
AND FIND LOVE IN EACH DAY.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER TWO WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN DR WEBER
AS SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
DOCTOR WEBER.
PLEASE JOIN ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible] ZERO IS A LITTLE
[inaudible]
A STRONG.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY NINETEEN
THE ASSEMBLY MET AT NINE AM ON
WBAL KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEM OF THIS ON THE PRESIDING
CHIEF COOKIE DOTSON WILSON AT
THE DESK.
READING QUICK KATHLEEN M. LOUIS
READING THE ROLLS HER BONTA
MOVES AND MISTER LACKEY SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADRIN NAZARIAN.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER VINCE FONG.
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JORDAN CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible] FOR ILLNESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IAN CALLED
AROUND.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREDDIE
RODRIGUEZ AND FOR A FUNERAL.
DEATH IN THE FAMILY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN MAIENSCHEIN.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN AA AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW. TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MISTER SPEAKER I FOR THE REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT.
FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER QUE HAN AND CHEN TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUESTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
EVER SINCE YOU'RE BIGELOW HAS A
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER I'M
GOING TO RECOGNIZE MISTER
BIGELOW FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER MISTER BIG WILD
FLOWERS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE HONOR WOMEN TOMORROW
FOR INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY.
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MISS
CALIFORNIA TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
TO THE FLOOR.
MISS MCKENZIE FREE.
MISS MCKENZIE FREEDOM WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN LODI CALIFORNIA.
SHE IS A SUMA **** LAUDE
GRADUATE OF CALIFORNIA BAPTIST
UNIVERSITY.
IS FRIEDMAN I HAVE A LOT MORE IN
COMMON THAN WHAT MEETS THE EYE.
OBVIOUSLY.
THIS IS A AND I'M MISSING A
CROWN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE BOTH DISNEY INTO CS.
LET ME SHARE WITH YOU.
HI HAVE THE DISNEY WATER.
AS YOU ALL KNOW MISS
CALIFORNIA'S A PROMINENT SYMBOL
OF POPULAR.
POP CULTURE REPRESENTING
INTELLECTUAL AND TALENTED YOUNG
WOMEN EVERYWHERE.
IN HER ROLE AS MISS CALIFORNIA
MISS READ ADVOCATES.
EDUCATE AND ENGAGES WITH VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS AND CAUSES BOTH
NATIONALLY AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE MISS CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATION
UP HOLD THE LONG STANDING
TRADITION OF EMPOWERING AMERICAN
WOMEN TO ACHIEVE THEIR PERSONAL
AND PROFESSIONAL GOALS.
MEMBERS LETS WELCOME MISS
CALIFORNIA CONGRATULATE HER ON
HER SUCCESSES AND WISH HER THE
BEST OF LUCK.
IN YOUR FUTURE ENDEAVORS MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME GIVING HER A WARM
WELCOME
.
MR BIGELOW YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED
IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO TAKE THE MOMENT TO
ENERGY IS.
MACKENZIE'S PARENTS MEMBERS OF
MEMBERS.
DOES YOUR ATTENTION AS BIGELOW I
WOULD LIKE TO ACTUALLY TAKE A
MOMENT TO WRAP A TEST BE GONE
THE FOLKS WHO HAVE MADE IT
POSSIBLE FOR THIS YOUNG WOMAN TO
REPRESENT.
ALL OF US IN CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE
TO HAVE MISS FREDDIE AND GEORGE
FREED THE RECOGNIZE TODAY AS
WELL MISTER SPEAKER WOULD YOU
ALL PLEASE.
GIVE MOM AND DAD THE BACKBONE OF
MISS MCKENZIE.
PLEASE THANK YOU
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO MS
BURNER HARBACH AT HER DESK MISS
BERHARAP.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
THE KIDS OF THE COSTA HIGH IN
CROSS THAT.
THEY'VE COME UP HERE THEIR CLASS
TRIP WAS CANCELED BUT THE MOMS
AND THE KIDS DECIDE TO COME UP
HERE ANYWAYS AND LEARN ABOUT
SPECIFICS IN CALIFORNIA.
WANT TO WELCOME THE KIDS OF THE
COSTA HEIGHTS PLEASE JOIN ME IN.
ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FOURTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS AND ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
THERE IS REMOVING A ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR PASS AND
RETAIN.
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE ON ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
THIRD READING.
THIS IS A C. R..
THIRTY THREE SEPARATE ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
AT RELATIVE TO LYMPHEDEMA
AWARENESS DAY.
MR GLORIA ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND ASK
FOR THE AYE MY COLLEAGUES
ATTENTION AS I RISE TO PRESENT
ACR THIRTY THREE WHICH DECLARED.
MARCH SIX THEM EVERY YEAR TO BE
LYMPHEDEMA AWARENESS DAY.
MEMBERS ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND ALL AROUND THE WORLD FOR
THAT MATTER ACTIVISTS DID
TOGETHER YESTERDAY TO RECOGNIZE
WORLD LYMPHEDEMA DAY.
LYMPHEDEMA IS A SERIOUS CHRONIC
DISEASE THE PLAGUES NEARLY TEN
MILLION AMERICANS RITA BORN WITH
THE CONDITION OR WHO DEVELOP IT
AS A RESULT OF TRAUMA SURGICAL
INSULT RADIATION THERAPY.
OR COMBINATION OF THESE FACTORS.
IN FACT THE NATIONAL CANCER
INSTITUTE PREDICTS OF 42%
INCREASE IN CANCER SURVIVOR
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER
BY THE YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY AND AS MANY AS ONE
POINT FIVE TO THREE MILLION
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WHO ARE
CANCER SURVIVORS WILL REQUIRE
TREATMENT FOR THEM THAT THE
DEMON.
AND FOR THOSE YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT IS YOU HAVE A PHONE
GOOGLE IT YOU FIGURE IT OUT.
BUT THE POINT OF THIS MATTER AS
A LUCIEN IS TO RAISE AN
AWARENESS TO BRING ATTENTION TO
THIS CONDITION THAT TOO MANY
FOLKS FEEL THE NEED TO HIDE AND
AS A RESULT DOES NOT GET THE
ATTENTION IT SO DESERVES.
MEMBERS TIMELY DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT ARE OFTEN NOT
AVAILABLE TO PATIENTS
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WHO LIVE
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES.
MEMBERS MANY OF THE TREATMENTS
FOR THIS CONDITION ARE NOT
COVERED BY INSURANCE.
AND THAT LEADS TO MAKING A DIEM
EVEN MORE DID NEGATIVE HOW
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES DO THAT LAYS
IN BOTH THE DIAGNOSIS AND THE
TREATING OF THE CONDITION.
FORTUNATELY FOR US THEY ARE
TIRELESS ADVOCATES LIKE SOME I
WOULD REDUCE IN A MOMENT AFTER
WE VOTE.
I WHO HAVE DEDICATED THEIR LIVES
TO IMPROVING THE OUTCOMES FOR OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE STRICKEN
WITH LYMPHEDEMA.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE MISTER SPEAKER I
ASK THAT THE WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION THE AUTHOR IS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THE
CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED TO THE RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAME.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
AND MR GLORIA BACK TO YOU FOR
YOUR SPECIAL GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
BEFORE I DO THAT I WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GLENDALE --
WHO WANT TO MEET HIM FOR SIZE TO
MY TO ALL OF US THAT --
AS I MENTIONED CANCER LOOK AT
HIM AS OFTEN AS I SIDE RESULT OF
CANCER TREATMENT PARTICULARLY
TRUE FOR WOMEN WHO ARE BREAST
CANCER --
AND OBVIOUSLY THAT'S ALSO
SOMETHING I KNOWS VERY
PASSIONATELY --
FOCUS OF MANY OF YOU --
AND THAT THESE CONNECTIONS ARE
POOR TO MAKE REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF A I HAVE GUESTS HERE TODAY
THAT I MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO
I'M PROUD TO INTRODUCE SHELLEY
DOWN HERE.
AMY KATERINA SERRA BRUNSKILL AND
BARBARA HARMER --
SAN DIEGO OR NOT --
IF YOU GUYS.
THEY ARE MEMBERS.
OF THE LYMPHATIC EDUCATION AND
RESEARCH NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THEY HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO BRING AWARENESS TO
THE DISEASE OF THE DEMON IN
CALIFORNIA.
I ASK ALL COLLEAGUES TO PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM TO THE
STATE ASSEMBLY AND THANK THEM
FOR THEIR HARD WORK AND RAISING
AWARENESS WAS OF ONE IT WILL
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE WE VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
ONE ROLL CALL VOTE AND ALLOW ANY
MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR
TO THE RESOLUTIONS.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
COUNTER.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY TO BUY SOMETHING NUMBER
FLORA RELATIVE TO COLO RECTAL
CANCER AWARENESS MONTH.
AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GABRIEL
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL SPEECH AND
DEBATE EDUCATION DAY.
CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE TO
ALLOW ANY TO ADD ON AS A CO
AUTHOR. TO THE RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTIONS.
IF YOU WISH TO ADD YOUR NAME IS
A CO AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTIONS
ON CONSENT.
PLEASE REGISTER YOUR VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE SEVENTY CO
AUTHORS ADDED TO THE RESOLUTIONS
THE CLERK WILL APPLY THAT VOTE
TO THE RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT.
WE ARE NOW MOVING TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITSELF DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING HEARING ON THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TWENTY SEVEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
LACKEY AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS CONSENT [inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
ITALIAN BUT I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED IN THE CLERK WILLREAD
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT.
I SEVENTY TWO NOW ZERO ON THE
URGENCY.
I SEVEN TWO NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
THIRTY TWO I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY NINE I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
FORTY I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTEEN I SEVENTY TWO NO
.
ZERO I MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY MARCH EIGHTH NO FLOOR
SESSION AND NO CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY MARCH ELEVENTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION.
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR
.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MS BAUER QUE HAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMANY
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MADELINE HEARD OF SAN
RAMON.
WHO IT TWENTY ONE WAS TAKEN FROM
US TOO SOON LAST MONTH?
MADDIE GRADUATED FROM CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
WHERE SHE PLAYED FOUR YEARS ON
THE WOMEN'S VARSITY WATER POLO
TEAM.
SWAM AND WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THE LEADERSHIP PROGRAM.
GROWING UP MATTIE WAS A FIERCE
COMPETITOR IN THE POOL AND A
DEDICATED FRIENDS.
S. GEARS SINCE SHE WAS FOUR SHE
WORKED AMOUNT BAKER AS A SKI
INSTRUCTOR SKI INSTRUCTION
SUPERVISOR.
FOLLOWING HER LOVE FOR THE
OUTDOORS MATTIE PURSUED A DEGREE
IN RECREATION FROM WESTERN
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY.
MADDIE WENT ON TO COUPLE HER
LOVE FOR THE OUTDOORS WITH
EDUCATION.
BY WORKING WITH TROUBLED YOUTH
YOUR RECREATION THERAPY PROGRAM.
WHERE SHE WAS ABLE TO TEACH
OTHERS ABOUT HER PASSIONS?
AND MAKE A POSITIVE IMPACT IN
OTHERS LIVES.
MADDIE HAS BEEN DESCRIBED BY HER
COMMUNITY AS AN AMAZING YOUNG
WOMAN.
SUPPORTED BY A WONDERFUL FAMILY.
IT TRULY IS A TRAGEDY TO LOSE
SOMEONE THIS YOUNG.
AND OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO HER
FAMILY AND THE ENTIRE SAN RAMON
COMMUNITY.
MADDIE IS SURVIVED BY HER
PARENTS ALEC AND RACHEL HEARD
AND BROTHERS DAN AND ADAM.
MISTER SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MADELINE HEARD.
THANK YOU AS FAR QUE HAN.
BACK TO CHAD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS ARE RISE WITH A HEAVY
HEART TODAY.
BY THE ASSEMBLY DRAWN IN THE
MEMORY OF BILL KRUGER.
A FORMER MAYOR CHINO HILLS AND
ADDED VOLUNTEER IN THE COMMUNITY
HE PASSED AWAY ON EVERY TWENTY
SIX IN YOUR BILL IN A CALIFORNIA.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JANET
KRUEGER.
BILL WAS BORN ON OCTOBER TWENTY
THIRD NINETEEN FORTY FIVE IN
CHICAGO.
HE SERVED IN US MARINES FROM
NINETEEN NINETY SIX TO NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE WAS VERY ACTIVE THE
AMERICAN LEGION UNIT.
OR THE ALSO THE COFOUNDER OF THE
WE'RE HIS PASSION WAS HELPING
YOUTH.
ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM TROUBLED
FAMILIES.
HE ALSO WAS INVOLVED IN PUBLIC
SERVICE IF YOU LOOK AT THE CHINO
HILLS CITY COUNCIL IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SERVE TO TWENTY
TWELVE INCLUDING TWO TERMS AS A
MAYOR CHINO HILLS.
WAS A PLANNING COMMISSIONER FOR
NINETY SIX TO TWO THOUSAND AND
WAS A LEADING WATER EXPERT.
IN THE CITY.
HE WAS ALSO ACTIVE IN THE PATROL
ENVIRONMENT IN THE CHINO HILLS
INCIDENTS PATROL.
WE PATROL THE STREETS AND WAS
KNOWN TO EVERY CONCERT.
AND THE GO THERE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE EVENTS THE PRODUCTION
NEEDS OF THE CHILDREN OF
GENERAL'S.
HE DONATED PUMPKINS.
THE SONY TURKEYS.
ISRAELI CANDY CANES FROM SCHOOL
TO SCHOOL TO SCHOOL.
MY FRIENDS I ASKED FOR YOU TO
PLEASE A TURN.
IN THE MEMORY A MISERABLE
KRUEGER HUMANITARIAN.
LIKE THE OFFICIAL BUT MOST OF
ALL.
A LOVED ONE IN THE CITY OF CHINO
HILLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHANNEL.
MEMBERS PLEASE READ THE NAMES
THE DESTINY PRINT IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUESTS TO RETURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN.
SEEING HER IN A FOR THE BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
MISTER RAMOS MOVES.
AND HIS POWER QUE HAN SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY MARCH ELEVENTH AT
ONE PM WE ARE ADJOURNED